You're making mistakes with your first
impression that you can't see. And when
these mistakes happen, it doesn't make
you forgettable, it makes you
incorrectly memorable. And because of a
bad first impression, you now spend
every future interaction trying to
correct it. My name's Vin, I'm an
international keynote speaker and
communication coach. Over the last
decade, I've met a lot of people, and
this is what I've come to realize. It
only takes your brain a tenth of a
second to form a read on someone when
you meet them for the first time. And
before they've even said anything, your
brain has already decided who they are.
Now, imagine when someone meets you,
what first impressions are you creating
without you even realizing? I'm going to
show you what each one of these five
components look like in order, and the
exact behavior to replace it with. This
doesn't just apply to networking, it
applies to whenever you're meeting
anybody for the first time. Component
number one, how you walk into a room.
Most people walk into a room, and the
first thing they do is they find
something to look at that isn't another
person. They look at their phone, they
look at the ceiling, anywhere but the
actual person. Your brain often defaults
to making yourself small, which forces
you to close yourself off with closed
posture. But what does this signal to
the people in the room? Well, it tells
them that you lack confidence in
yourself. You don't think that you
belong in that room, and you have low
status. And without you saying even a
single word, people have already made
those judgments, whether they're true or
whether they're not. So, how do you fix
this? I call this the doorway reset,
[music] and it's something that I've
learned from one of my theater coaches
back in the day. He said to me, "Vin,
your posture introduces you before your
words do." So, every single time you're
about to walk through any door frame,
readjust your posture. Because when you
enter a new room, you're creating a new
impression. And I've just anchored this
in my mind anytime I walk through a door
frame, and I want you to anchor this
into your mind as well. Before you walk
through any door frame, readjust your
posture. Stand tall, shoulders down and
back, and the center of your head,
imagine a piece of string pulling it
nice and high. Then walk into the room.
And just this tiny shift makes you not
only look more confident, but when you
introduce yourself and you speak, you
sound more confident as well, because
your body is connected to your voice and
your voice is connected to your body.
Now you're in, but the next mistake
usually happens in the first 10 [music]
seconds of meeting someone new, and it
can make or break relationships.
Component number two, remembering their
name. This happens to all of us, and it
goes a little something like this. Yo,
Vin, WHAT'S UP, MAN? OH, WHAT'S UP, VIN?
Good to see you. Oh my god, I've seen
you in Andy.
Champ. Man, it's good to good to see
you. Oh, Andy. Andy, oh, dude.
>> TO HAVE TO HELP ME OUT, BROTHER. I
forgot the guy's name. Help me. I got
you, man.
Hey, name's Andy. Nice to meet you, man.
What's your name?
I'm going to let this guy introduce me,
cuz he used to do it to me all the time
in university.
Nah,
I I have no idea who the you are,
man. Oh, man, I hate situations like
that. Oh my gosh. Now look, the common
advice that you would often hear people
say is, if you want to remember people's
names, just repeat their names in the
first minute of you talking to them, and
that helps with memory. Now that does
work, but you've got to be really subtle
about that, because you don't want to be
like, "Hey Craig, nice to meet you,
Craig. Craig, what are you doing these
days? Craig, how are you?" Craig, again,
that's just going to be weird if you do
that. You need more than just this
strategy. And here's what I like to do,
and it's something I rarely hear people
talk about. And I've used this technique
to remember the names of my students at
my workshops, and even [music] recall
the names of people I've met years ago.
It's a very powerful technique, and it's
called name association. When someone
tells you their name, immediately attach
something to that name to make it more
memorable. It could be a unique physical
feature or a quality about that person.
It could be an alliteration, a rhyme, an
exaggeration, something that your brain
can grab onto.
>> [music]
>> And the more silly or vivid or wild the
association actually is, the easier it
is to remember their name. So, if I met
a bloke named Michael, and the first
thing I notice about him is that he's
got arms the size of my head, then I'm
immediately going to be thinking,
"That's a massive Michael with
Vin-shaped biceps." So, I imagine in my
head little Vin heads around his arms.
It's a freaky picture, but that's how I
remember massive Michael. And for
example, if I meet someone named Sarah
and I notice she's always smiling, now
in my brain she's smiley Sarah. And one
more example, if I was trying to
remember Craig's name, who's here with
me right now in the studio, he's always
behind the camera, so then I would call
him Craig the camera camel. Why camel?
Well, because the guy doesn't drink
water. He never drinks water and he
always drinks beers. Actually, I'll
rename him. He's going to be Craig the
alcoholic. See, now I'm never going to
forget Craig's name because I've forever
associated his name with alcohol.
Okay, jokes aside. Can you see what I'm
doing here? The more of a stronger
association you can create with that
person, whether it's with a physical
feature [music] or a play on words or a
combination of both, then it's easier
for you to recall their name. And if you
use this technique just two to three
times, it will lock their name into your
memory for good. Now, this is what you
shouldn't do. You should not tell Big
Nose Barry what his alliteration is.
Some of these descriptions are not
appropriate for public consumption. This
is purely an internal filing system that
you have just in your own head. Because
like I said earlier, the more vivid the
exaggeration, the better the connection,
the more you'll remember it. So, keep
this to yourself. So, why are we going
to so much effort to remember somebody's
name? Well, because somebody's name,
it's the sweetest sound that they can
hear. It shows that you're attentive and
it makes people feel valued and it
deepens your connection with them more
than you realize. When someone says your
name 20 minutes after you've introduced
yourself, even though you've only said
it once, doesn't it make you feel seen?
Doesn't it make you feel special? All
right, now you've got their name. You're
in the conversation. But when you
actually open your mouth, this is where
it often falls apart for a lot of
people. Component number three, how to
use your voice. When you think about
making a good first impression, what's
the first thing that comes to your mind?
It's probably how you look, your outfit,
your hair, your glasses, your shoes,
right? This is visual image, but here's
what nobody teaches you,
>> unfortunately. A great first impression
is made up of two parts, your visual
image and then also your vocal image.
Most people only focus on their visual
image. Again, that's how you look,
that's how you use your body language,
what you wear, etc. But rarely do they
think about their vocal image, which is
how they sound. And here's the crazy
part. You can buy your visual image. You
can buy the watch, you can buy the
glasses, the nice shirt, but you can't
buy your vocal image. Your ability to
communicate well, that's something that
has to be earned.
Most people spend 20 minutes trying to
look good before they leave the house in
the morning. But when was the last time
you spent 20 minutes trying to sound
good? Because you can have a strong
visual image, but the moment you open
your mouth and you reveal your vocal
image, people are creating perceptions
about your level of authority, your
level of status, credibility, and
whether or not they can trust you, how
friendly you are. All of this is made in
an instant, the moment you open your
mouth and reveal the vocal image. So,
what does your vocal image reveal about
you without you even realizing? If
you're just sitting there thinking, "All
right, but how do I actually get better
at this?" The first step isn't to start
applying random communication tips you
find on the internet to yourself and
hope that it makes you a better
communicator. No, you don't do this. The
first step is self-awareness. And why is
this the first step? Because when you
identify what your communication blind
spots are, then you can apply the right
behavior changes that are specific to
you, not just random tips, because
random tips get random results. And what
I'm about to recommend here, I know most
of you are not going to do. But to the
top 5% who are going to apply this, it's
going to feel uncomfortable. I know it's
going to feel uncomfortable. However, if
you lean in and do it, it's going to
change the way you communicate forever.
Are you ready? It's for you to record a
video of yourself speaking to camera. I
know, it's so scary, Vin. I don't want
to do it. Come on, mate. Just do it. You
need to see yourself the way others see
you when you communicate. Otherwise, you
never get to see yourself from a
different perspective. You never get to
see yourself cuz you're always looking
at yourself through the lens of your own
eyes. This is going to give you a lens
outside looking at you. This is what
helps you develop the self-awareness.
So, open up your camera app on the
phone, set your phone on a tripod or a
table, use the back camera so that you
don't see yourself while you're doing
this. Otherwise, you're going to get all
self-conscious. Hit record and then
start talking. It has to be unscripted.
Now, what am I going to talk about, Vin,
if it's unscripted? Here's a simple
solution. I want you to just to go to AI
and ask it to prompt you between five to
10 questions that cause you to
self-reflect, that force you to get to
know yourself better. You might as well
make the content of this video something
that's going to help you in your life.
It's going to reveal your non-functional
behaviors, and it's also going to help
you dig deeper into who you are as a
human being. A very important piece of
information here. This video that you're
recording needs to go for at least five
to 10 minutes. Why? Because we need a
large sample size of how you currently
communicate so that we can tease out all
of those non-functional behaviors. Once
you've got this video, you must leave
the video. Don't watch it. Leave it for
24 hours. We are way too judgmental, and
if you watch it straight away, you're
not going to be able to continue the
rest of the process as effectively as
you can because you'll think to
yourself, "Oh, I don't like the way I
look. Oh, I don't like the way I sound."
Leave it for 24 hours. Create some
separation. And once you have the video,
24 hours later, you now have the perfect
material to go and do a deep analysis on
your visual image and your vocal image.
And I don't have time to go through the
complete process here, but I have
created a free guide. It's a three-part
video course designed to help you do
exactly this. So, if you want to learn
exactly how to identify your
non-functional behaviors that you need
to focus on and work on, just click the
link in the description and access the
free training there to help you develop
that awareness.
>> [music]
>> Or you can scan the QR code on screen,
too. It's completely free. It will take
you no more than 45 minutes to complete
the process. Look, I need to hammer this
point home. You can focus on your visual
image all you want, but that's only 50%
of the puzzle. So, really start to
master your vocal image paired with
great visual image, and now you're going
to create the best first impression
every time. Component number four, what
you say. So, you've walked in the room
with presence. You've locked in their
name. You've shown up with a strong
vocal image. Now comes the part most
people get wrong. They think making a
first-grade impression is all about
being impressive. It's not. Most people
walk into a conversation thinking, "What
do I say next? How do I sound? Do they
like me?" It's me, me, me, me, me, me,
me. And the moment your attention goes
there, you stop being present. Think
about the people who you've met, who've
left a mark on you, who've left a great
impression on you. When you met them,
were they doing something different?
Did they listen more than they spoke?
Think about those interactions. These
people always look out for the small
details, [music] the threads that they
can pull on to get to know you better as
a person. In other words, they're
interested in you. They're not always
putting the focus on themselves. I have
a friend named Phong, and everybody
loves to be around him. And Phong, if
you're watching this, hey brother, look
at you. You've made it into one of my
YouTube videos. What a privilege for
you, brother. But you see, the thing
about Phong is that people love being
around him not for the main reasons why
you think. [music] He is not that
charismatic. He is not the loudest, and
he's not even that funny. Yeah, Phong,
you're not that funny. But you know what
he's really good at? He's amazing at
listening. [music] Because in every
conversation, he knows how to ask the
exact right questions. He knows how to
dig deeper with you, to go below the
surface level conversations, and
everybody loves him. Heck, they love him
more than me. They tell him more secrets
than they tell me. And I used to always
look at him like, "Why?" But, he has a
secret power. Good old Vin over here,
trying to always be the one that's the
most interesting, Fong has learned the
importance of being [music] interested
in others. So, be the person who notices
others. [music] Be the person who
listens for what's underneath the words.
Ask them about their world, what they
care about, what they do, what they
love, what they're building, what
they're [music] hoping for. Because the
moment someone feels genuinely seen, the
conversation changes. It stops being
about networking, and it starts being
about connection. [music] While
everyone's out there trying to get
attention, you're now the one trying to
give it.
>> [music]
>> So, what am I trying to say here? Be a
little more like Fong, and a little less
like Vin. And that brings us to the
final component. Because everything
you've done up to this point, it all
fades if you can't do this last part
correctly. Component number five, what
you do in the 24 hours after. Here's the
move that separates a good first
impression from one that actually lasts.
Within 24 hours of meeting somebody new,
send them a follow-up message. Not a
cheesy LinkedIn request with a generic
note, not an Instagram follow-up, an
actual message. It doesn't need to be
fancy. It just needs to be really,
really specific. So, let's just say you
met somebody at an [music] event, and
during that conversation, because you're
now more like Fong, and you listen
better, you pull on certain threads, you
learn that they've been trying to get
better at exercising. And you saw that
their eyes lit up when they were talking
about exercising, but then you also saw
their eyes kind of start to dim when
they said, "Ah, but I'm really
struggling with staying consistent." You
remember all of these, and then you
connect because you're on the same boat,
because you've also been trying to
exercise too. And that's something you
bonded over. If you're going to send a
follow-up, you should send them
something like this. Hey, it was so good
meeting you last night. Listen, I know
we both spoke last night about being
more consistent at the gym. Here's
someone who really inspires me. His name
is Eugene. He's been able to help me
achieve a lot of my fitness goals, so
you should follow him, too. I think it's
going to help you achieve your goals.
And you know what? By the next time we
meet, I bet you we're both going to have
biceps the size of basketballs. Hey, it
was genuinely great chatting with you
last night. Hope to see you again soon.
That's it. No pitch, [music] no ask,
you're not trying to get anything out of
it. You're just trying to show that you
cared and that you were present, that
you enjoyed the conversation you had
with them the night before. And there's
one goal you have after this. So, after
you've sent that beautiful little
message with no strings attached, then I
ask you to be curious. Be curious about
how you can help that person achieve one
of their goals in life. As opposed to
you immediately making an ask and going,
"Hey, oh by the way, I'm an agency. Can
I help you with this or I can help you
with that?" Instead of doing that,
before you ask people for [music]
something, give first. This is such a
rare trait [music] to have now. So,
after you send that follow-up, they
might send you something back. I would
[music] suggest the next thing you send
them is that, "Hey, by the way, if
there's anything I can ever help you
with [music] to achieve your fitness
goals, let me know. I'll be more than
happy to do so." Because when you help
somebody first, now you're applying a
rule, and it's rooted in psychology.
There's a principle called the law of
reciprocity, and it says that when
someone gives you something with no
strings attached, even something small,
even just a thoughtful message or a
thoughtful connection, your brain
naturally now wants to give back. And
you might be thinking, "But Vin, isn't
this manipulation?" Yes. Yes, it
absolutely is.
Don't you know that's my plan the entire
time?
Don't you know that's the purpose of
this channel? Is to do evil things and
No, I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
I couldn't follow through with that,
because I'm not evil. And this isn't
evil. It's not manipulation. It's just
how the human brain is wired. We're
built to return what we've been given.
[music]
So, when you send that message and you
help the other person, there's no by the
way, I would also love to pick your
brain now because I've helped you, so
you're going to help me, right? No, you
don't say anything like that. It happens
naturally. When the other person knows
that you are being genuine, that you are
trying to just help, they feel like you
care. They remember you differently than
the 10 other people they met the night
before at the networking function.
[music] And when that happens, they want
you in their network. They want you in
their circle. And the only way you can
have a quality connection with somebody
is if on the night when you met them in
the first place, you had quality
listening abilities. It's not about
being transactional. It's about making
the other person feel seen, feel heard,
feel understood, and to make the other
person feel cared for. Start the
relationship with a genuine connection
and seriously, just watch what happens.
You can thank me later. Remember, if you
want to create a strong first
impression, make sure you click the link
in the description and learn the full
self-awareness process that's going to
make you aware of what you do visually,
that's non-functional, the sounds you
make that are non-functional, even some
of the things you say that are
non-functional. So, check that out in my
free three-part video course in the
description below, or you can scan the
QR code up here.
I'll see you in the next video.